immaginate di essere nell'oscurità
davanti a voi una parete di roccia
adesso nel buio infilatevi l'imbragatura
cercate i primi appigli e arrivate fino
al primo chiodo e poi al secondo e via
via fino in cima
difficile forse diciamo che ci vuole
molta immaginazione
no no ma se per cui perché questo in
carica c'è la cosa me le sento poi però
quando veramente solido poi infiammate
lavoraccio tale centrali per oriente
ma la catena
ma dove
trovata
adesso sarà un dramma qua respira giulia
rimane ancora un po che tiriamo mai dai
ragazzi ma qui c'è lo schermo il
pubblico le nostre spalle di uniforme
merita iniziamo bene
ecco evidenti tracce di disabilità ciao
io sono giulia e sono quella che avete
appena sentito nella disperazione più
totale
volete sapere com'è andata a finire
quella volta beh quella volta è andata
bene
sono arrivata in cima e ho messo la
corda incatena come diciamo noi
arrampicatori qui ero in roccia ma
normalmente faccia arrampicata sportiva
su parete artificiale sono agonista
nella categoria b2 ovvero la categoria
degli ipovedenti molto gravi ma come fai
ad arrampicare che lo vede gli appelli e
c'è carla che mi dà le indicazioni lei
legge per me il tracciato dal basso e la
sua voce mi accompagna e di presa
impresa durante tutto il percorso e per
evitare di urlare a squarciagola
utilizziamo degli auricolari con un
microfono il metodo di guida che abbiamo
sviluppato negli anni è piuttosto
complesso e si basa fondamentalmente sul
quadrante dell'orologio per muovere le
mani mentre per i piedi utilizziamo
anche le parti del corpo
e adesso ve lo facciamo vedere allora
bionda abbiamo quattro pannelli in
verticale e altri quattro paronelli
leggero strapiombo prima presa di
partenza parti accoppiando qua e al
piede sinistro al ginocchio sinistro ok
poi avrai un altro piede qui all'anca e
vai a 11 poi fai una incrocino a una è
di nuovo un ok ok
quando sei pronta parti ok piede
sinistro ginocchio sinistro ore 11 piede
destro ginocchio destro
una incrocino a una piena e sinistro al
ginocchio destro e destro esterno
ginocchio destro e una di nuovo
umiltà
in realtà il metodo di guida è
abbastanza complesso ma dopo anni di
allenamento e di lavoro insieme ai
carracci intendiamo alla perfezione lei
conosce bene il mio stile di arrampicata
e io so decodificare con precisione le
sue indicazioni che dovrà essere il più
possibile rapide e sintetiche poi sta a
me tradurle sulla parete di arrampicata
utilizzando la tecnica giusta
a me piace molto la sensazione di
leggerezza e di autonomia che provo
quando mi muovo in verticale arrampico
da sei anni e dal 2012 faccio parte
della squadra nazionale di paraclimbing
ho esordito a 15 anni ai campionati del
mondo di parigi conquistando la medaglia
di bronzo e altre ne sono seguite
l'ultima è di colore argento ed è
arrivata a luglio di quest'anno ai
campionati europei diciamo ni
ma aperta aggiunge all'arrampicata cosa
per me l'arrampicata è una via sempre
nuovo navi a chi mi conduce verso
qualcosa di misterioso
non importa a vedere cos'è basta
percepirlo e voi ragazzi cosa ci fate
qui sono matteo anch'io non ci vedo e
come giulia sono atleta di paraclimbing
così si chiama l'arrampicata praticata
da atleti con disabilità mi alleno a
bologna è solo campione del mondo di
velocità e sono stato nel 2011 anche
campione del mondo di difficoltà la
velocità la specialità d'arrampicata
sportiva su parete artificiale della
specialità veloce per intenderci mentre
la difficoltà una specialità che
richiede padronanza della tecnica
capacità di improvvisazione di
interpretazione del tracciato e questa
specialità stan dei risultati riesco
piuttosto bene quest'anno
lasciamoli mi sono laureato campione
europeo e io gareggio nella categoria
io gareggio nella categoria b1 che
quella per intenderci di chi non vede
proprio niente
se tu matte come fai ad arrampicare in
velocità non civili nella velocità possa
scatenare tutta la mia esplosività come
un centometrista personalmente corrotto
sul tracciato omologato alto 10 metri
con 19 prese lo conosco a memoria così
posso correre in verticale in piena
autonomia il mio record personale su un
tracciato molho gato è di 8 secondi 41
ma quando quando fai difficoltà anche tu
sei guidato anche quando faccio le
difficoltà sono guidato da carla e fin
da bambino mi divertivo ad arrampicare
su grandi masse oppure un po più da
grande in montagna con mio padre e
dell'arrampicata mi è sempre piaciuta la
sensazione di libertà che si prova con
carlo iniziato nel 2008 per the matter
arrampicata cos'è per me varo implicato
un istinto mi sento di rabbia un istinto
di libertà un istinto di calma tenacia
pacatezza un istinto da opposti un
istinto che esplode un istinto che
scorre leggero al servizio della porta e
migliore che c'è in ognuno di noi e
tumore ciao sono giulio anch'io se non
atlete di paraclimbing e come giulia e
la legge nella categoria b2
ho iniziato proprio insieme a lei nel
tu mate arrampica vigia ci ha ispirati
così abbiamo incominciato anch'io faccio
gare di velocità e di difficoltà ma la
difficoltà la preferisco perché i
tracciati sono sempre diversi e c'è
sempre una sfida nuova dove mi metto la
prova difficoltà dopo difficoltà dovendo
trovare rapidamente soluzioni di
successo e quando un passaggio non mi
riesce
ci provo e ci riprovo finché non trova
la soluzione giusta
non esiste rinuncia l'arrampicata mi
tempra e mi permette anche di affrontare
gli obiettivi della vita con entusiasmo
e determinazione
il bello e soprattutto il condividere
tutto ciò con voi con gli amici
anch'io mentre arrampico sarà guidata da
carla ei ragazzi se sono qui se siamo
qui è perché noi facciamo parte della
stessa squadra
ma allora secondo te
noi siamo coraggiosi qualcuno dice che
lo siamo ma ogni tanto anche noi abbiamo
paura soprattutto quando arrampichiamo i
roccia ma la paura è una parete che deve
essere superata come tutte le altre e
toccarla che cosa ci fai qui dai ragazzi
anch'io faccio parte della squadra se no
voi che vi sta dietro
ma lo faceva in avvocato tu sì l'ho
fatto per 24 anni poi a un certo punto
mi sono accorta che come avvocato aveva
esaurito ogni curiosità che non mi
identificavo più in quello che facevo
così prevaleva un senso di compressione
troppo forte che non tollerava più
la sera invece quando era in palestra
come istruttrice di arrampicata stavo
bene e quello negli ultimi anni era
diventato l'obiettivo delle mie giornate
ma avevo un'alternativa molto valida
così ho deciso di cambiare anzi di
andare oltre e di seguire la mia honda
come la chiamo io
certo che ha avuto un bel coraggio a
ripartire da zero e ragazzi cioè per
cambiare un po bisogna buttarcisi con
curiosità e positività e bisogna
azzerare i contachilometri
si riparte da zero è vero ma il bagaglio
pieno così come quando in cima alla
parete si torna a terra ed a terra si
riparte per quella successiva poi voi
eravate giovanissimi mi avete dato una
forte spinta il lavoro che facevo con
voi attirava e attraeva la mia curiosità
era una continua esplorazione una
continua scoperta una nuova sfida che mi
ha appassionato e mi ha preso poi poi
sono anche successe cose che mi hanno
fatto riflettere su chi sono cosa voglio
e così ho capito che la mia parte
dell'avvocatura si era esaurita e che
come era iniziata una nuova avventura
umana
una nuova sfida che mi ha appassionato e
mi ha preso e capace di rinnovare
potentemente i miei entusiasmi
beh non mi sono sbagliata insieme
abbiamo fatto tante cose abbiamo fatto
scoperte sorprendenti tanti incontri
impensati siamo cresciuti e tanto oggi
siamo una vera squadra è cresciuta nella
consapevolezza e dalla partecipazione di
fede di pietro che abbiamo incontrato
due grandi che abbiamo incontrato lungo
questa parete invisibile e che hanno
deciso di stare con noi e che anche
stasera sono qui con noi e che salutiamo
ragazzi
noi
noi siamo gli occhi e voi le braccia le
gambe abbiamo imparato a muoverci
sincronia ea metterci in gioco con
fiducia reciproca e solamente accettando
il rischio di non farcela insieme
possiamo arrivare in cima
per cui la prossima volta che voi sarete
di fronte alla vostra parete da superare
al buio anche se avrete la fortuna di
incontrare una persona di cui fidarsi
che sia la vostra guida
ricordatevi che le mani che stringeranno
gli appigli saranno le vostre se vi
capiterà ad aver paura
non rinunciate la paura sarà solo
un'altra parete da superare